today i'm going to talk about
one of the best
things you can do
for clear skin but not just for acne
but for overall wonderful amazing
youthful looking
skin now before i dive in there's
something very important i want to
mention
i want to ask you a very very big favor
there's a survey that i want to do to
find out
what
information
what videos you would be most interested
in and i would really really really
appreciate if you filled it out at the
end of this video i put a link down
below for this survey that way i don't
have to guess so much of what topics you
might be interested in all right now
let's dive in now if you look at the
mirror right now and you look at your
skin do you notice that your skin is
oily or dry or flaky or does it have
little red dots do you have aging spots
do you have wrinkles
do you have acne what does your skin
look like
for me as a teenager my skin was
absolutely
terrible i had the worst acne boy
there's nothing worse for your
self-esteem than having a lot of acne
it really makes you avoid people it
makes you shy it is terrible for your
self-esteem and if you're watching this
and you have acne or you know someone
that has acne send this video because
after you watch this video and apply
what i'm going to show you
you won't have acne anymore but this is
not just about acne it's about having
youthful looking amazing skin this trick
that i'm about to reveal is extremely
expensive and i'm just being very
sarcastic because it is the cheapest
thing on the planet it actually is
free it costs you
nothing in fact
you'll save a lot of money you could
save up to
three to four to five hundred dollars a
month okay just by doing this one thing
and then end up with
not just wonderful skin but some other
cool benefits
a better metabolism you may live longer
a better immune system less need for
medication
etc etc and if you guessed
asking
you're correct
the benefits of fasting are amazing and
again they go way beyond just your skin
it can actually improve infections okay
if you have a viral infection or a
bacterial infection or you just want to
strengthen your immune system fasting is
the answer it's wonderful for your
vision in your eyes any type of
eye problem if it relates to either
cataracts or glaucoma or diabetic
retinopathy fasting can help mental and
cognitive issues i'm talking about
mood improvements uh improvement in
memory focus and concentration also
literally you can grow
new brain cells okay with this
simple
cheap remedy called fasting decreasing
your risk for cancer and even if you get
cancer doing fasting can actually get
rid of cancer i've done videos on that
anti-aging and hormone health you see
when you do fasting you greatly reduce
insulin which then can help regulate
androgens
and
greatly improve acne from
polycystic ovarian syndrome or even high
levels of extra androgens which are
causing the acne what i'm going to show
you is based on some really amazing
studies that they did on ramadan there
were significant improvements on the
following from
the study that i'm going to put down
below
dermatitis itching of the skin
inflammation reduction acne psoriasis
and rosacea okay
so
i mean this is actually quite
fascinating the question is how can you
like starve your body and improve your
skin it doesn't make sense well you're
not starving your body
you're basically just mimicking what
your body has been designed
to do
and that would be go for a period of
time without eating it's only very
recently that we started eating so darn
frequently because food is available
everywhere
and now we have like six seven
meals a day we're constantly grazing
that is the absolute worst thing you can
do for your skin and your health because
every time you eat you trigger insulin
and insulin is behind so many problems
including skin problems so the opposite
of doing frequent eating is
fasting so you're just mimicking what
your body is designed to do and has
developed all sorts of genes
that turn on
and can help you survive you actually
survive better when you don't eat so
frequently there's significant increase
in stem cells these are cells that are
undifferentiated they're not
determined yet they're just kind of
basic cells and they can turn into
whatever you need at the time
so we're basically replacing
the damaged cell with the new cell this
is called anti-aging right so you
increase your stem cells
number two autophagy what is autophagy
autophagy is a
condition
where your body recycles
old damaged
cells okay so
it will basically take the damaged cells
that you have
from various reasons
and it will replace them so you actually
have new
wonderful amazing skin cells okay so
that's one thing
also
there's a certain hormone that's made by
your liver it's called igf-1 okay it
works like growth hormone so when you
increase
igf-1
you can increase collagen growth because
as you age you lose collagen at least
you lose collagen one
fibers and then you also lose your
elastin which your skin becomes brittle
it becomes atrophied and loose
so fasting can help tighten your skin as
well it also increases this other thing
called a v-e-g-f which basically
increases blood flow to your skin
and decrease uh scarring from
certain things that can damage your skin
because you get an overall wound healing
and you also have the autophagy which
actually can help get rid of scarring in
the skin especially if you have
like pock marks from acne things like
that
and then generally what it can do is it
can reduce inflammation which is the
most powerful thing to make your skin
look good so many people are walking
around with general redness of the skin
rashes which is caused by inflammation
so if we can reduce that
all of a sudden your skin looks amazing
now like i said before the worst thing
for the skin is frequent eating okay
uh sugar carbs omega-6 that would be
like the seed oils very inflammatory for
the skin
stress i don't know if you notice this
but when you go through stress your skin
just kind of wigs out it just does not
do well because of the cortisol and that
also increases insulin it's kind of
equivalent to eating sugar basically and
stress increased cortisol which breaks
down your proteins okay and your skin is
part protein allergies
see fasting can actually improve
allergies and allergies can create skin
reactions food environmental a toxic
liver and a toxic colon can affect your
skin greatly and guess what fasting can
improve that as well now the gallbladder
okay your gallbladder
stores and concentrates bile that helps
you break down fats because your skin
is part fat you need the gallbladder to
pull in
these key omega 3 fatty acids as well as
the fat soluble vitamins vitamin a and
vitamin d so without a gallbladder or or
without bile your skin kind of looks
kind of messed up also going on a
low-fat diet really destroys your skin
and your hair so we need a sufficient
amount of fat in our diets to have nice
skin
autoimmune
you could have an autoimmune problem
with the skin psoriasis sema things like
that well guess what
the best thing for autoimmune conditions
is fasting
because it helps your immune system and
it drops inflammation
and then as you get older you lose the
collagen like i mentioned in elastin
well guess what autophagy
building up new stem cells can
greatly turn things around now how do
you do fasting very very s
simply okay
this is the simplest way i can explain
it okay just skip your breakfast okay
have coffee add some mct oil in your
coffee it makes things really easy and
it gives you these things called ketones
that will decrease hunger and you have
energy
to make it to the first meal which is
lunch
now the first step is basically don't
change what you eat just
do two meals a day okay that's it no
snacks
don't even change what you're eating
make it simple first meal is at noon
second meal at six
no snacks in between don't even worry
about
how much you eat okay just two meals
guess what's gonna happen
you're gonna have 18 hours of fasting
plus if you don't eat between these two
hours you have an ad additional four
hours that's 22 hours of fasting do you
know what that would do to your skin
it would be incredible not even changing
what you eat okay just from the fasting
now that would be step one now to make
it even better we reduce the carbs we go
in a ketogenic diet
and then of course gradually go into
phase two which is the healthy version
of the ketogenic diet
now there's some additional things you
can add okay and
sun being outside that vitamin d and
also the infrared of the sun can greatly
greatly help your skin
your gut has a huge influence over your
skin
so either taking a probiotic or
fermented foods like sauerkraut
kimchi
kefir
very important with your skin
and then the last thing which is kind of
a little ninja trick is the cod of oil
if you took cod liver oil you would get
not just omega 3 fatty acids but you get
vitamin a
and vitamin d
which you don't get in normal fish oils
so
omega-3 is like a fish oil on steroids
now i don't want you to forget about
this survey so i put that link down
below i really really appreciate you
doing this survey and that way i'll know
what to do the next video on
and the next video to watch okay in this
series is one on fasting so you have all
the details of how to fast correctly
check it out i put it right here
you